et qu'est-ce que je dois dire que je
veux dire oui jamais fait ça je me sens
comme si je suis allé coller à j'étais
un mauvais élève et je dois est a été
volé ma classe pour m'expliquer pourquoi
je fais des conneries mais voilà il
commence à s'affaisser décollant à os je
pense que c'est un bon accord est une
bonne école non c'est une des meilleures
écoles de business je pense et ça passe
et c'est surtout le monde ici et là en
poupe dans les business c'est ça tout
parce que je vois que tu connais bien
j'ai une belle belle belle belle belle
jean-louis sur son business kusile
voudrais vous devez savoir comment
devenir riche sans arrière fait c'est ça
comme auckland et à la maison regardent
la télévision et de travailler de chez
toi et qui se la joue sa honte bien et
est que les autres travaillent pour toi
et tu as beaucoup de petites mains si tu
deviens riche se voit là je suis un
exemple de quelqu'un qu'il a fait tout
le contraire de tout ce que vous faites
voilà je suis le mec à qui tu disais va
7 pour la i man je vais à cette peur là
je fais tout en contre le système
tu vois pas ce que le système ça
marchait pas pour moi c'était pas pour
moi au sort jeudi à voilà ils n'ont même
ma mère on monte parce que je vais
devant mon immeuble a mis devant ma
porte chez ma mère y avait
mes voisins dont s'amuse voisins et bien
sûr où il était à la bonne école il est
fait columbia university est ce que vous
connaissez comment bien versé soit ça
c'est les écoles tu vois que ça coûte
cher il faut voir discours le chef bien
quoi faire pour pouvoir graver montreuil
et moi j'étais toujours comme ça
dégueulasse ça marchait pas ce home et
voisins il faisait les bancs d'école y
moi ma mère tout jeu mais prenez la tête
régal pablito régal point les gars qu'on
me sont illégales toi mon fils pourquoi
tu es habillée comme ça pourquoi tout
fait pas les bons écoles comme eux et
moi je disais même lâche moi lâche moi
je suis pas souvent ça elle a continué
me prends la tête à cause de ça pour des
années et moi ça marchait pas tu vois ça
complètement je fais les options
j'ai commencé à attaquer mon ombre dans
l'immeuble tu vois j'ai fait des jeux
fait j'écris mon nom donc tout mon
immeuble
rapoport produits longs parce que je
m'en foutais 3 et après j'ai traîné
devant mon immeuble je traînais devant
memup avec mon mon pétain il m'a bien tu
vois tu vois je voyais tout le monde
comme con comme vous passez devant moi
disait c'est qui ces losers la vie va
jamais réussissent relativement c'est
toi c'est comment pour le maxitest voir
le site heise vous connaissent pas les
sites s mais tu vois devant le site et y
retrouve toujours les mecs ce qui traîne
devant les sites des voix qui crachent
pas t'es tu vois ça c'était moi toi mais
moi j'avais des confrères quand même tu
vois je vais des grosses grosses fêtes
ce bref je commençais à taguer dans mon
immeuble
jusqu'à les cordiant démons immeubles et
la montée chez ma mère et elle a dit est
faux que votre fils et l'arrêtent de
taguer aussi non nous va le foot vous
foutez de moi et voilà c'était sale
histoire ma mère est venue vers moi et
m'a dit il faut que tu arrêtes ta gueule
et mup t.ac.b au dollar jour ce sera ça
a commencé comme ça mais si toi tu vas
c'était
mais elle m'a béni tu vois là dit vas-y
dollars ou savoir là je dis voilà je
veux ta gueule à la rousse je commençais
comment comme un business plan
comme vous vous êtes en appréciations
business plein mais un business plan
dans mon quartier je dis voilà je vais
attaquer mon ombre ici et je vais
attaquer mon homme là bas comme ça et ça
fait un pur marketing aussi parce que
c'est tout à l'ombre
les journées passent ils voient ça après
j'avais de réponse tu vois pas ce que
les gens disaient et john wayne j'ai vu
ton nom mais crise est écrit la voix ce
jeudi wars se voit ce que je fais la
publicité gratuit monterosso ça je vous
apprends tout sacrées du monde ça vous
fait il ne remontèrent gentil je vous
paie je vous fais ça so je commençais à
taguer dans la rue devant wire ma pièce
où mon bétail tout ça est très laid fait
la fête voix galériens sans argent mais
la vie était belle elle s'était bel
tomber le moment il préfère me après des
tags et détaillée des tags et des tags
et tagué ont mieux commencé à rencontrer
des artistes voient par hasard j'ai
commencé à traîner avec des artistes est
il prêt face et moment là j'ai vu que
c'était mieux la vie de l'artiste
qu'elle est mieux d'être et d'avoir un
vrai boulot tragédie plus tabou si je
veux travailler pour quelqu'un de non
bio euros
yvon chéry travailler dans les systèmes
de primes et de 30 jours je veux devenir
fou je peux pas fait ça c'est pas mon
dilemme saint john je vois pas jouer ce
système je vais devenir fou jeudi je
préfère être pauvres sont urgentes que
travailler dans cette si ce temps je
vois déjà m avait pour quelques uns
n'ont jamais jamais jamais je préfère
travailler pour moi et il gagne mon nom
propre et un gentil qui travaillent pour
quelqu'un sans preuve que je galère
je bouffais la terre je vous dise
annette va tourner en rond jaune et
anthony ronde il prêt femmes j'ai
commencé à rencontrer des artistes de
bons artizi aude c'est un petit cela ils
ont commencé à s'exprimer différents
mondes qui mes amis qui parlait la
guerre doit savoir où tu vas y avait une
vision personnelle
tu vas y avait un sentiment tout
discours différentes que les autres gens
que je traînais avec un is avait ce moi
je dis ouah ça c'est court dit il devait
le poncho oui à la cirrhose ok donc
selon lui ce jeudi wassa sécurisons ils
ont une vision un peu différente
ce jeu commençait à traîner avec des
artistes voix et sa soeur sa mère ouvrez
ouvrez mon mahmoud à moi tu vois c'est à
poutine était là et après je commençais
à lier à des vernissages il traînait
avec des gens friqués avec tout va
j'étais là à les voir c'est super c'est
différent que mon quartier il bref à ce
moment là je commençais à expérimenter
moi même avec des toiles twice as jeudi
si un oeil peau pourquoi pas moi tu vois
je sors ça c'était le but
ça c'était le début des des john wang
devoir maintenant un prochain deuxième
partie oui ça c'est mon vrai nom jean un
doctorat lancée par john wall mon vrai
nom c'est john andrew russo à partir de
ce moment là je suis arrivé à paris
après tout niké paris je te défoncer jeu
la police n'y comprenais pas je d'ivoire
fait un village devant les gens sont
gentils ici ce sera tout ou massacrait
toi je le tague et surtout ils s'étaient
je me suis bien amusé
et après j'ai commencé avant l'atelier
j'avais en at il y est ça c'était même
beaucoup calmé j'ai commencé à me donner
dans les monts de l'artois dans le monde
des galeries et tout ça oui ça c'est un
pur comment tu peux devenir riche situe
sur cette formule là et est célèbre
tu vois mais comme je pense que tu vois
le sujet c'est le progrès
tu vois c'est sale et c'était ça mon
sujet c'est le progrès sommes sur le
progrès c'est un pont c'est très très
important tous ces sales que lors de
tout le monde les progresser dans le
second c'est non attendu ce thème mais
progresse est très très important
travail et à un sérieusement
sérieusement tout va je me rappelle très
bien les jours que je commençais à
réfléchir sur le progrès soit j'étais
peut-être un homme 16 17 ans et je
regardais un stand à a
je les gardais star wars avec comme d'un
facteur ix luke skywalker bordeaux et je
regardais ça je disais utilisé mais
petit agent tu vas mourir un jour tu vas
plus et de l'avancée dans cette planète
là il faut que tu fais quelque chose
plus importante qui l'argent donc que le
business et tout ça tu vois je dis
faut que jean teulé son transport
est faux que faut que tu fais quelque
chose gronde grande comcom et rendent
grande comme hollande grande comme
george bush tu vois tu fais une chose tu
vas tu te laisses se laisse sur nes
quelque chose grande comme sarkozy
grande tu vas te fais comme dsk tu vois
quelque chose grande tu vois je dis je
le regardais salade star wars avec luke
skywalker entre le jem et fo ce sera
cette petite graine qui est entré dans
ma tête voit que je dis j'ai faut que je
vais je vais en eau des mois même de
voirie mais je savais pas je savais pas
et après je vais la passion aussi
non mais sérieusement sérieusement je
parle d'une autre chose parce que 100 de
ma tête maintenant je vais vous avouer
quelque chose tu vois pas ce que vous me
voir ici tu voudrais voir lui
ça y est le cas comme la bière égard il
c'est la réussite cela soit vous vous
devez dire ça dans votre vous dit très
impressionné par par mon lot députation
meknès c'est un hôpital de trop beau et
trop beau nom mais je voudrais voir vous
avouer quelque chose tu vois il sait
c'est une chose très importante pour tu
vois ça c'est le moment de se mettre
silence tu vois ces titres rock tu vois
c'est toi c'est très important de femmes
ça c'est le message dur loin de toi
c'est un jeu s'y construit je me suis
construit vous ne va pas quoi vous
pensez que je montre à ce moment là mais
je 6 mai construire avec des échecs
non mais vraiment je fais beaucoup d
erreurs dans ma vie l'homme est des
choses que j'ai même honte à vous avouer
et je vois je vais vous
je joue au hockey je dirait quelqu'un
c'est pas plus mal
non mais je suis vraiment construit avec
des échecs
tu vois vraiment vraiment jeter les mecs
raté de rater deux ratés de rap et de
ratés mais qu'est-ce-qui mais a
construit et moi même c'est c'est pas la
réussite la réussite ça c'est du bla bla
bla ça c'est ça c'est des roulettes
ça sert à ça qu'on parte vois ça mais ça
m'intéresse pas devant l'effort de jeu
non non ça c'est pas bien qu'est ce qui
m'intéresse c'est comment tout à
confondre et des échecs
mon gars ça c'est ça sinon tu vois ce
par exemple avant avant je fumais des
cracks
tu vois je je je je commençais s'appelle
jeu je fumais d un jeu mais ce l'effet
la côte voix non mais ça c'est des
choses que j'ai vraiment honte vraiment
je ne devrais pas vous dire ça tu vois
pas ce que peut-être une manière vous
êtes 20 ans vous êtes vous et votre
plein mais j'avais des gros ce problème
tu vas j'avais des gros ce problème mais
qu'est ce qui met à construire moi-même
sais c'est pas ça c'est comment je dois
confondre et les echets ce chacun de
vous vous ennuyez après l'avis de bobo
la vie de la vie dès lors la violette ça
va ils envoient des années ça va tu vas
toujours oui ça va ça va bien ça
mais en vérité qu'est ce qui va devant
la vie devant vous il y aura beaucoup de
tombes qui va être diot qui vont être là
tu vas voir des galets à près d'égaler
acquis après qu'est-ce qui se met ce
moment là comme tu as beaucoup des
galets et beaucoup des problèmes c'est à
ce moment là que tu va construire ta
propre et au personnel est-il peut-être
peut-être et c'est ça que je vous
souhaite peut-être un jour vous pour
devenir comme moi vraiment
stop merci